perhaps both father used to say there
were no right answers had the light to
guide you have the light guide me all
right let's go frame a slide more
[ __ ] things result the tests have
been going well the most long-term and
in a sense the most promising one is the
light box having to steen choose a slide
essentially a mood for every day is a
great way to see the lottery overall
development over mine she definitely
reads things in two slides I had not
foreseen her remarkable imagination
turns the character in just about
anything and she is able to effort lira
deuce all her experiences into one of
the four characters slide using the
puzzle locks has proven more difficult
yet she tends to always choose to sides
with character facing the same way I
have asked her why this is but she
doesn't seem full fully understand Pam
asked me and we picked up one of them I
guess it's a [ __ ] puzzle
that's good thing I should be that I'm
so MLG sigh bottom up here
you're a freakin omnium I can throw up
finally you kept throwing nightmare
how's life without drunk routes or I
can't pick that up did I hear something
that's like this characters have we
thought about winning wars
it's not light follow the light
[Music]
I don't like thank God
this looks expensive yeah all right I
got another slide what thing is not as
that big the same she wants to do it
later all right you got it one came for
don't really trust you guys gonna lie I
don't trust you a bit Oh
watching you paint I remember dear ah we
got whatever
I think that's Justine actually at the
third ah you can see his penis okay
soldier nurdle and he's just seeing h8
today I played outside with players we
saw a bird picked at a snail it carried
it off and then on the lawn fence the
snail had a seashell and it cracked fire
and Claire's cried and comforter when
you made it heard us and came out and
scolded Claire's for playing me the
third took off into the air today I was
one
with open arms 89 today I play with the
slides from father diaper above all I
like the man signing through the right
father ask why I said he see things he
likes today I was the right age 10 the
father said I picked the wrong side
yesterday when I made the chambermaid
cry
he wanted me to pick one with the sword
I'll I picked him I own on the right I
never pick the one with a sword today I
was age 11 today father came in my room
my silcoon flew him in the eyes he said
I shouldn't be ashamed that I only wow
that guy has a penis who's there this is
the penis man I don't talk to penis man
let's do one more thing that's so
disturbing that's so [ __ ] disturbing
one more thing
things that door doesn't open we open
nice now
you're bad for what you do holy [ __ ]
this game is so [ __ ] disturbing I
don't even know what I did okay let's go
to another room there's candy and
marshmallows
as always don't like that thank you very
much
oh [ __ ] I don't have much oh there's
another slight we have I have four there
was four right it would make sense of
this there's only four let's listen to
what she has to say
it's father David with his God now maybe
you helped him there
don't you worry I'm sure you didn't have
a family we can't all be safe some don't
even want to be saved yes that is a
comforting thought that some try I guess
that makes sense
hug the wall
Capricorn Kevin Akana Camden Captagon it
oh no no no no no something bad is about
to happen something bad is about to
happen something
for that but I'm gonna I didn't even
ever laughs okay nice
what the [ __ ] was that okay
I hear footsteps I definitely heard
something
[Music]
doing anything just tap it in the corner
don't come here please you probably
couldn't see in though this is so
[ __ ] good
ah I can see him don't look at it like I
got a stick I haven't missed my bro
it's [ __ ] me
[Music]
still there he's [ __ ] ah
is he patrolling are you kidding me
okay I'm thinking bigger yep see you
later guys
you